now it is time for a sit-down a chit
chat and informal roundabout with the
editor-in-chief of reason calm and
reasoned TV Nicol SP or as he's known on
the streets here in DC Nikki snap Matt
Welch who happens to be the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine which
sounds so much more legitimate we get a
lot of them it's lasted longer so let's
start with a piece that you wrote about
the most ridiculous law I've seen in a
long time mostly because it directly
affects me because there's nothing I
enjoy more than balls on the beach but
now that it's officially banned what
happened in LA County County Board of
Supervisors passed a an ordinance or
they revised an ordinance making it
illegal to dig a whole trench moat to
your sandcastle dig deeper than 18
inches and to play frisbee on the beach
unless it's between certain months of
the year these laws were written because
they mistook Frankie Avalon and Annette
Funicello for Mexicans or something
possibly I know there was an actual
quote from a County Board of superman'
said well listen you know you don't want
to be on the beach when a spontaneous
game of football breaks out no I
actually do i I do I would like to watch
that and I would like to be a part of it
that's actually very enjoy it Skye I
mean for me it's the whole points of
California was to goof off at the beach
roll frisbee maybe throw a frisbee once
in a while there's no dogs there's no
driving there's no bonfires like
anything fun you could do at the beach
is Aleve you can't even build a bonfire
at night except if you go down to Orange
County it's ridiculous so Nick when I
think of you I think gay marriage and
and so much don't when I think of May I
think of gay divorce I won't tell
Frederick you said that so let's discuss
some of the gay marriage laws in various
states where are we in the state of this
game there's you know Washington state
just passed a legislatively passed law
that the governor signed into law making
gay marriage legal it's the seventh
jurisdiction
six states and Washington DC allow gay
marriage when you look at long-held
social institutions and social
prejudices when they are actually
examined and you're asked to justify
them more often than not that crumbles
away it happened with gays in the
military it happened with racial
segregation it happened with the
International marriage and you know
loving versus Virginia in 1967 like
suddenly everyone woke up and said you
know if we have to justify this on paper
it looks really really good states
rights issue versus gay marriage I don't
think so in the sense that the people
who say this is something that should be
decided at the state level they don't
say that about heterosexual man at some
level everyone is a hypocrite when it
comes to federalism there is a strong
you know inclination and the smart one
to say let's hash a lot of this stuff
out at the local level let's not come up
with a federal solution that's fine but
then you have the same politicians who
will say that in one breath will then
pass the Defense of Marriage Act
night-night I think when I think of
cultural libertarianism one of the
things I think of is the war on drugs
you know which is still they still beat
the war drums in the social conservative
moment but it's so incredibly dangerous
I mean as Mexico devolves into civil war
we realized that that war has failed the
war on drugs in America is a war on
marijuana marijuana is the only widely
used illegal drug and most of law
enforcement you know power and resources
goes to marijuana prohibition now where
are we with States legalizing marijuana
there's a couple of states that have
gonna have it on ballot initiatives in
November 2012 Colorado is definitely
going to do it and it's looking very
good that Colorado will be the first
state to actually legalize the
production and sale and distribution and
use of marijuana this sets up a huge you
know fight between the federal
government and state governments who
gets to preempt the courts have been
totally clear the Supreme Court is
totally no federal preemption takes you
no precedent it's it's going to make me
sad that Ron Paul is not the Republican
nominee probably more than anything else
for that question what would happen if
there is a Republican who wants to
legalize heroin running against Barack
Obama who's cracking down on the war on
drugs
worse than george w bush in a year
whether there was full legalization on
the ballots in places like Colorado and
Washington have we ever seen such a
cultural juxtaposition in presidential
politics no and this is you know the sad
thing about the drug war even more than
you know the presidential elections
no but I mean this the drug war is at
Vietnam 1973 and you know to remind
people of what John Kerry said who wants
to be the last person to die for a
mistake it's like you know from now
until the end of the drug war which
could be you know a year from now it
could be ten years from that but it's
definitely coming who who are we gonna
sacrifice to fight you know a rearguard
action and a losing war because that's
where we're at if you want to check into
any of these issues go to reason.com
whether its cultural libertarianism gay
marriage or tossing a frisbee and
getting a thousand dollar fine
everything we talked about you will find
links there Nikolas meet Matt Welch
awesomeness thank you